all right this is really exciting
it's really happening fist bump fist
bump you guys the merch is here
it's coming we we literally we begged
you begged and we cried listen a lot has
happened and we wanted to take our time
to get the perfect merch for you and we
have so many cute things i think we
nailed it we have a crew neck it's got
slugs crawling on the front trash
tuesday on the back it's so amazing it's
in a golden yellow we have a windbreaker
the banana light pink crop windbreaker
is so cute like by the way it's such a
good thing because not everyone has a
windbreaker so we were like let's do
this this is we're into it and there's
postcards and stickers
i'm so happy i know i'm really excited
they're really i feel like we
put in the time and effort and we came
up with stuff that you guys are really
gonna like yeah so you can check out all
our new merch at slugfam.com
guys we want to shout out natalie
ramirez and her instagram natalie
presents she made all of the cards and
thank you so much natalie you made our
merch so cool stickers it's just really
very exciting that she did a beautiful
job and we're
very happy to be working with her and we
love you guys so much
hey slugs welcome to trash tuesday um
what you're gonna see later is us
getting to the bottom of who on the show
is a cuck and who is a regular person
um you can see me
you can there are a lot of laughs i
gotta start real good on this one
she fell to the ground she was bruised
knees for me i think i even hugged you
she hugged me we had a moment we had a
couple moments you can come see me live
i've been having the best time on these
shows you can come see me live uh in
irvine california naples florida hasbro
heights new jersey
brookfield
wisconsin
tampa florida springfield missouri
washington dc austin texas and many more
please go to andyletterman.com
come see me it's been unbelievable can't
wait to meet you
hi you guys
today is a day
i'm coming to salt lake city and austin
and more come see me get tickets at
estronice.com i'm so excited to come to
all these cities we've been having so
much fun we've been having so much fun
and check out
sleepoverbyester.com for
these sweatpants and more
[Music]
okay here guys we're gonna start we're
gonna a second attempt at starting this
podcast with a wholesome 10. you need to
hire crisis actors oh my god that's
actually so funny we should get like
little kids dressed in our wigs yes
we need crisis actors we're little
people but we might get in trouble for
that what is today's uh topic for the
first 10 minutes of
non-sexual non-rape talk i want to tell
you uh brad williams i saw last night
okay two very different wholesome
because you started with brad williams
because i'm wearing these i'm wearing
these
you can't be wholesome and short wow
rape and sexual are two different topics
okay yes
and rexual is actually a new thing we'll
be talking about later
okay so you saw brad williams and you
wrecked him you saw brad williams and
your eight inch platform yes and i felt
so guilty i was like brad i'm so sorry i
was like i should have gotten you a pair
i have i've failed you you know it's
also rude to me too i don't care about
your feelings do you understand
and that's what makes me want you even
more your child passable brad is a grown
adult who's little you look like a small
child
i do love brat i really
he is such a good he likes you you don't
want to be like a total hack with him
but i've had some good ones with him
sarah tiana and her boyfriend were at
the comedy store other day and brad was
with them and i went oh my god you
brought your son
and it was so good is he he's considered
a little person yeah okay
just clarifying that i mean you are
actually too but
when i meet people at the i'm always
like oh my god you're exercise i always
let them know
that's all they want to know
how small is it you and joe rogan
they're like how tall
joe is
shockingly small he's not as short as
they think that he is though i think
he's she's taller than me
no he's not annie because you and i are
the same height and when i when i go in
to hug him he's definitely shorter than
me i think his neck is thicker than
yours oh his neck is six times thicker
than my waistline and he's taller than
all of us
no i always you know when they had the
thing the uh joe rogan is he's not five
eight he's absolutely not because i'm
five eight i'm five eight and i go i i
hug down i'm five well that's because
you're a snob
it's not punching down anymore it's
hugging down am i crazy that five eight
is like tall yeah five eight's at a
great height until i wear listen i don't
even notice when i wear these heels the
security guard at the comedy store is
like top why maybe he's the manager now
but he's like really tall and i now like
i came in yesterday was like oh my god
and i was like you have no power anymore
i don't even trust i don't feel safe
anymore with you i need to be the
security guard now these heels are like
it's an equalizer i love it every week
there's like a new thing that makes you
stronger like first it was the
sunglasses which by the way
oh my god you got them too
[ __ ]
and how do you feel does your life feel
better yeah dude
i'm a peasant
i know am i a peasant no but we have
four hundred dollars these were four
hundred and i think sixty dollars for
sixty these like these are
bloomingdale's in the lower east side
bloomingdale's texas
new york new york
i finally i've wanted these like for ten
years not the i wanted celine sunglasses
for ten years i feel like you wanted
your eyes checked for ten years and
you're like why can't i ever get the old
lady glass and then you did the expense
of her kala she's rubbing off on me are
you scared i'm so happy her she's she's
she's
humping my leg sorry i got really
excited to deliver that and it's
meaningless
i thought that was pretty wholesome the
first time
it's like there's skull [ __ ] and then
there's the rest of the show
you don't have to describe what you're
not talking about yeah that's right
you're all making love no no skull
making love
making love to a head a cranium cranial
making love cranial lovemaking
this is feminism okay because we need to
get our nails done again there's no
competition left
my jewels have fallen off
my this got like started to get snagged
and so now it's just you don't say a
dangling but it had a good five days of
no doubt no tangle i just want to make
sure the camera really sees that you
have a key
it's a palm tree but i like that you
think it's a key oh palm tree is cool
for cocaine
we're gonna get you on some stuff no no
no no no no no no no boys though i had
the buck has to stop it at a boulder
dude i got the molly episode's gonna be
incredible
i didn't even tell you guys i got
another tattoo let me know
this is and she spelled it wrong is it a
real one no this is another like a mate
it's so funny that you're gonna get like
a full body fake tattoo okay i kind of
[ __ ] it up though because okay so the
tattoo is sunset boulevard it's weird
the movie you think it'd be like the
other
host but
i was expecting maybe
no that's when we're going to go
together we'll all get something so you
got a west coast tattoo in the east
coast i did i do realize that was maybe
weird but i just wanted to get it done
so i got sunset boulevard because that's
my favorite movie but then when i came
home dave was like you spelled it wrong
the movie spells it out but i got blvd
it just looks like like a street like
the street yeah you're like oh you're
really into the comedy store
yeah let's get comedy store tattoos on
our nipples ew you guys i'm wearing like
the chicken cutlets actually let me just
show you
those are such a throwback but they're
very fast they're very far set george is
looking down
george's is exasperated
and then but listen but they're like
really old they're
they're so like uh dirty they're all
over they're covered in fuzz
but is that all your nipple hair yeah i
can't do it
finally
saves me it's so cool is not working out
for us today you guys
i think these are awesome guys i lost a
wholesome ten i'll tell you that i'm
doing great on my my
exercising and
i look what i wrote down favorite pie
disney characters favorite pie
strawberry rhubarb
it's like how many we are hacks of our
own show we've talked about strawberry
we wear pub for 12 episodes but this
time hold my hand and gaze into my eyes
while i say it
it's a wonderful pie
it has the sweet uh sweetness of the
strawberries and the tartness of the
rhubarb and it's just it's better than
apple out of us who's the sweet in the
tart
i yell but you're annoying
[Laughter]
which is the which is the tart maybe
it's the official pie uh okay i have a
pitch
name strawberry rhubarb is the official
pie of the trash tuesday podcast i veto
that decision
because we're not 90. that's like for
elderly people so what would it be if we
had an official party something more
indulgent do you want something like
things that are easy on your teeth i
feel like
elderly people food
i love a key lime
that's um i like a couple things i like
oh there's this one in um cassells that
they have it's like a dulce de leche
banana foster thing
we should have a pie eating contest okay
guess who's getting their pie pie in
their face uh you may have seen us
poking his penis last week
oh i have a i have a really random weird
hawaii update
uh-oh
so dave is canceling
he's not coming
but he still wants to go
so he's making me go to hawaii with him
next week and then i'm flying back to la
for like four days and going back with
you guys
i feel a little bit disrespected that i
wasn't even invited on that hawaii trip
i
is this all because this is what i love
the reason esther is able to do it is
because carlos has a new niece or nephew
uh he has and you allowed him to go home
wait when i saw him playing with esther
let him leave
wait no he was he was with me in new
york and then flew
he hasn't met his nephew yet
was just coming back with you but he was
in coach and you were in first no we
were together oh we just didn't put you
in it no i know i took that photo of him
i don't he's cutting me out of the
narrative esther so you're doing two
hawaii trips in a span of two and a half
weeks that's very kalila that's very me
i am becoming you it's also very me but
let me explain like i'm super into
going somewhere like i'm super into
taking a flight that like is kind of
pointless like my dream is to fly to
paris land in the morning have go
shopping at like the skincare places
have lunch and then fly back to l.a i've
done that to kiss a boy
that's amazing i swear to god 4th of
july 2013
um um
my
guy that i was seeing at that time from
spain he was in new york
and i just so happened to have um a free
day so i got on a standby flight i was
stand by i got on so you were like it's
fate like if this works out ah no i just
he had a big dick
so
so why did you just kiss him
i kissed many parts of him did you ask
him god but he was not
and we're not talking about san fran did
you san francisco him
wholesome 10.
i got there at seven in the morning and
i remember wait where was it
to new york new york okay i remember
flying back at
7 00 p.m and having to type out my um
because i was still you know i was in
school at that time
and
i remember doing like a powerpoint story
that was at the end of the story and
brutally it was a brutal thing there's a
brutal
because i love a good rape story myself
obviously we know that but
kalila really gives some details where
you're like oh it's like what have you
ever seen like the hills have eyes where
the rape seems like a little too
realistic
because she sells she like doesn't she
reveals to the
she's like so this guy came and picked
me up you like know where his hands were
on her like oh my god
you guys no we love it it's not my fault
everyone has fisted me
i had to do a thing for the my coaching
program that i do it is not your fault
let's just i want to be very clear it's
not great it is esther's fault we don't
know how but we can trace it back it's
like seven degrees of kevin bacon we
will find out how esther is isn't it
crazy that we're so close in degrees to
kevin you know jenna hanging out on a
farm with goats and kevin bacon like it
looks like they're on the footloose farm
i'm like how what
i'm right there
it looks like you did dress for it i did
yes i did for a dance i can't help just
i always my all my outfits i want to
look like i can dance
and i can't but you can it's easy you
can such a myth that like you have to
have no anyone can learn how i don't
have a rhythm
no that's why them no i didn't say that
todd got me a metronome for my
[ __ ] for something and i was like
that does feel like are you just saying
i'm bad in bed what if we got a
metronome for [ __ ] to like figure it
out
dude i'm gonna make him listen to it
because when we dance listen when we
dance and stuff it's like it's a lit it
is a little you know what he we should
have a metronome for kissing because i
feel like kissing people just don't get
the rhythm right for that like i like
slow and deep and sometimes it's a whole
lot of
i like i am famously a bad kisser i'll
just get that out of the way you guys
out of the breath
[Laughter]
fast and big i just like get too excited
i'm just like you have very pillowy lips
too thank you people say i kiss like i'm
in junior high like i just like let's
are you all tongue then yeah a lot a lot
kissing in junior high was like where
your mouth would be open and it wouldn't
the lips would never move and you'd be
like
yeah oh that looks that's good yeah i
dare you to touch nicki right away do
not just don't say anything and just go
kiss her
really yeah
is that assault oh you were kidding but
you were about to do it
it's a new person i always wanted to do
a prank show but then i realized i would
have been the one that was doing all the
pranks and you would have just been
standing in the back and laughing but
look
hi guys thank you for having me have a
seat of course
sit just down whoa did you put your
cutlets back thanks
yeah we can play with them okay
i'm not gonna do what you told me to do
but i'm gonna ask nikki and i want you
to be really honest with me nikki yeah
it feels so good to catch you like i
need you to be 100 honest okay um yeah
i'll be honest okay if i if you walked
in and just to be funny and cool i came
up to you
and i
kissed you like a man like kind of like
a man like put her hand like like open
mouth a lot of tongue just would you
push her away would you have been like
that was weird yes but only because my
breath is kicking but well
but
but if it would have been like soccer if
you know what i mean i think i might be
gay for how my body responded when you
said that like i think elaborate
welcome to the show
you know
better place so we have a sound effect
for when a woman comes out listen
jessica kirsten came on the show and
just popped that [ __ ] open for all of
us i mean it really did she really did
she open your eyes to the fact that
everyone's gay it's just really not only
that is everyone gay but we all want to
be skull [ __ ] by a dildo apparently
wait not not a male penis no a dildo a
strap-on
i want to quickly explain to nick okay
yeah we're we're a pro face [ __ ]
podcast okay we think it's very feminist
to be face [ __ ] yes i like it too why
are we yeah we don't have to we don't
want to do the work during things we're
not cervical movements that's exactly i
i was in my special but i was like i
like when a guy grabs my head and just
like does what he wants to do because i
don't want to guess his rhythm so i like
i called it the birdhouse like he treats
my head like a bird i don't know why
like i just feel like i just have a hole
in my head and he and i like being whole
and then when you're done and then when
you're done he tells everyone you're i
just want to be holes sorry wait wait
literally that's one of my favorite
statements to say i die
i just want to be like just the whole
thing
when you try to not be the whole they
treat you like the whole anyways you're
like wait why am i fighting against this
i'm a sock i'm a whole i love being a
disembodied like from my soul from being
a good person and like a daughter i want
them to be like is this the bed or my
girlfriend like i don't want them to
know the difference between the two i
love just being like i was lis i was uh
reading about like hot things to say in
bed because you kind of run out of
things and i need more and one was use
me like your [ __ ] slave and i was like
that like turned me on for some reason
to just be i want to be used i don't
want to be because sometimes it gets
twisted where i the guy that i'm like
hook up with will maybe sometimes think
that i want to be disrespected i just
want to be as disrespected as you would
treat a hole in the wall like you would
be like
you're a hole in the wall i want to be
limp like i want using my body like i
want to be limp and you just move me
around i want to do the least amount yes
annie yes
yes yes yes to all of this i want to be
a come dump yeah i want you to just flip
me over nicki doesn't know i have a i
have one of those hospital beds and i i
zoom up to [ __ ] my boyfriend i zoom up
the bottom i scooch to the edge and i i
guess
yes and i rise myself to his penis i do
nothing it's so hard to do stuff oh god
i don't like to do anything i really do
like to just take it and um i remember
one time my boyfriend at the time uh i
was really tired and he was like horny
and kind of petting on me and stuff and
i go you can but like i'm just gonna lay
i'm not gonna do anything and he goes
as opposed to what
he was like oh is that gonna be
different for us and i was like you're
right like you're such a good guy that
you never make me do anything like he's
he's really just i i don't ever have to
be on top i just don't want to be on top
i just i'll be on top every once in a
while but it's like it's just sometimes
i'm like oh to see if i miss it and i
don't know yes am i bad am i just bad
you're not bad you're just
i'm retired yes yes i'm on sabbatical i
already know absolutely
catch me at my peak i was you know
writing dicks off their bodies oh wow
i never did that i had a whole yeah i
like to be out i feel like my whole life
is so in control that most women that
like to be kind of just treated as an
objectified in bed i they tend to be
like boss [ __ ] in their life and they
just want a little time off like that's
why when i'm in bed i just want to be
holes i don't want to be like have to
think about your pleasure and
like think about you liking me and what
i look like i've spent so much of my
life doing that it's just so much
boyfriend the boss thing my ex boyfriend
used to be like you don't seem into i'm
like i'm here doing it like i don't what
do you need me to be like yay i'm just
like enough we've been dating for two
years you know what annie the more money
do a sit-up too why don't you get hotter
you're ugly that's true the more money i
make the less work i want to do yes oh
wait oh because money fixes everything
so i'm like why are you just throwing
money at this why are you telling
everyone about our sex life
do you want to sit up you're ugly
i've said it to you for years never
listen
do you guys feel like there's something
that's maybe getting in your way from
you living the life that you want i
think if you were to watch the show you
would already know the answer is 100
yes
i'm
obsessed with better help it's really
mental health
if you're not
working on it focus on it keeping it up
it will maybe you feel okay right now
but i promise you it's coming to bite
you in the ass and it's you need the
upkeep you need to put the work in if we
did not have better help and all use it
this show would be a lot harder to do
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can connect
in a safe and private online environment
it's so convenient you can start
communicating in just under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online and you can send a
message to your counselor anytime we've
all been in that position we're like i
just need to get this off my chest like
i just need to tell someone and that is
where better help really comes through
and it's all this all this can be done
without ever having to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room and i think a
lot of times we lean too much on our
friends we like unload on our friends
and it's really not their job but you
can just contact someone over your phone
an unbiased professional we want you to
start living a happier life today as a
listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com trash tuesday join over 1
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health again that's
betterhelp he
slash lp.com
tuesday
i find the holidays to be very stressful
and extremely triggering because they
don't have good rhubarb pie no well yes
actually things aren't how they used to
be no because the holidays are lots of
travel plan yes
and if you're a big family tons of kids
around pulling off all the shopping and
time
the gifts that you bought not coming in
when they're supposed to not liking your
gifts having to pretend you like them
with caliper cbd you'll feel better
before you finished your coco
i don't know i i got hungry and i'm
because you know what to say because you
call her coconut coco
why does it sound so when you finish
your coco
oh my god
who wrote this um honestly using caliper
cbd does just make things a little bit
more merry and bright
if you know what i mean for me it
decreases my stress
um i just generally feel calmer yeah
helps me sleep better i do like that
that's my favorite and you know what
surprisingly it actually helps me like
after a big workout with my pain and
soreness or any type of like rickety
feeling i'm having in my body i'll say
this with most cbd it's actually
impossible to know when you'll feel the
full effects but caliper cbd powder acts
really fast as in literally 30 times
faster than cbd oil and it gives you all
the benefits of cbd in just 10 minutes
in fact caliper is the only clinically
proven cbd brand on the market oh my god
and because it's a dissolvable powder
instead of an oil it mixes completely
into any food or drink with no grassy
taste or oily residue like this is the
way to go this holiday season be your
merriest with caliper cbd get 35 off
your first order with promo code trash a
try caliper.com
trash try it risk free for 30 days if
you don't love it they'll give you a
full refund that's
tricaliper.com trash don't forget promo
code trash for 35 off your first order
i just watched this um
french movie called titan that aquafina
suggested that i watched
and um there is a scene there without
giving too much away
where she is
fully having sex with an automobile
right like full on strapped on she's
[ __ ] it she gets pregnant by the
automobile right and i want to ask her
it was actually an old car which made it
even hotter but i want to ask you guys
have you ever had sex with an inanimate
object
no or been attracted to one or saw a
shape and said you know my room
i have like a it's not a sexual
attraction dude but i am able i look at
my roomba like a pet like it has
there's something about it that i'm like
oh i can understand why people have
robots and treat them like it's i feed
it and i'm like
yeah well i call it roomba even though
it's a shark and um
but uh i just i do feel like i could
have because of my like my relationship
with the roomba and like giving it a
personality and really believing that
and even when it gets tangled up in a
cord and like in the morning i'll go to
its dock and i'm like wait where is it
and i have to go looking for it and i
see i go room what were you doing why
don't you leave like a little bread
trail so it comes to you
or like just comes and sucks
but awesome you know i do want a body
room this is my this is my image of you
i want you to get a dildo and like glue
it onto the roomba and then ride and be
taken around yes
i i do think i could be attracted to
a thing like really almost anything
almost anything you know what because
the le this this is something i actually
did say because that's a common thing
you see in um my strange addiction or
those shows where a woman
uh will get married to the eiffel tower
and although that's phallic so she can
she actually uses
little um the ones that you would buy at
the gift shop she would use them to like
[ __ ] herself even though she's married
to the actual i got um married on
ecstasy once and we did eiffel tower
that night so i do kind of like
can you please remind those of us who
didn't do drugs in their 20s what it is
to eiffel tower eiffel tower is not
drugs it's uh when you're like no i i
know something yeah and then you high
five
each other while you're it's two guys
and a girl i think it could be girls
honestly we should be girlfriends
okay while we spit roast this
but i remember
i always thought that i had a type of
guy that i was attracted to like i have
i have a um
there's a bar you have to hit and there
was a guy you're like i also have a
typewriter
that's next for me
there was this guy that i like fell in
love with uh despite myself just like
there was this you know the energy that
people talk about that i was just
looking at i'm like
i don't there's if you would have showed
me a picture of like i want to set you
up with this guy i would have been like
do you hate me like i would have might i
would have swiped left so hard the
screen would have cracked this guy but
there was something about the physical
like just the energy between us and
after i was attracted to him and like
truly turned on by everything he had
going on i was like i understand why
women marry ferris wheels or like things
that you could never it was i could
never imagine a woman is closer to what
i'm a a guy that i usually am attracted
to looks like than this guy was like
that's why i was like i can date anyone
it's it's not about physical it's about
energy a million percent it's about the
connection with the person how they make
you feel how you make them feel like if
they let you be like a full lesbian on a
podcast yeah on the side
i mean every tuesday i'm not this is not
a joke this is not about every tuesday
like this show comes out and then like
around one o'clock i get a text
or like a look in the face from dave and
we have to go through all the things i
said wait he listens yeah that's sweet
he says he hasn't no it's not so he's
checking in he has to listen because i
learn about you know coming out this
week to see what i say because like last
two weeks ago he was like i noticed
kalila showed you her vagina and you
seem to really get excited by it
he's like so then he starts doing
mangina to like
is this what you're into
i suck thermometers up their asses
oh my god squishing up my ass for two
days it was great i thought about you
but it was it was high-end lube i hope
you know that yeah
so why did you take your temperatures
with um your ass it was just fun it was
nurses week okay yeah we were like okay
and kaleila used to be a nurse so i was
like uncomfortable
okay wait what did you feel about
kalila's vagina and what what was the
conversation that proceeded him saying
you seemed excited by it like what did
you do it was just a text
i was already in new york and he would
just i while i was there i got the text
or it was in skokie or something and he
was like yeah you seem really excited
about it and i just wrote like lol and
like i just try to i try to move on
quick right every time i'm in like a
little bit of a bad mood or anything
todd goes guess what day it is and i got
news tuesday i have tuesday anxiety for
some reason even though i love the show
there's nothing i don't know for some
reason on tuesday so now i'm like breath
work i'm like meditating i have no clue
why interesting i think it's because i
have to wake up with a job like when i
wake up i have to post the things do you
know what i mean yes usually when i wake
up i'm like thinking about my day and
like what am i going to do but then i
wake up i'm like huh and then you don't
the best part about not having anything
to do with the editing thank you again
kalylah and
you got to lastly gabby and style um
esther and i look at nothing
so it's a surprise i forget i forget
yeah i see the clips and then it's
really fun that's why i do a daily
podcast because i didn't want to feel
the pressure of once a week where it's
like gotta bring it i would i would feel
that way too but because there's four
days a week and if someone was like it
sucked i'd be like but i do this four
days a week i have so many things built
into my life to excuse why i end up
sucking well let me give you let me give
you a little tip this is a new thing i'm
doing in my career i have had my i have
now
a new task her task is to read the
comments pick out the good ones and send
those to me so i don't know that's nice
never is that not the great go for it
however she's reading the bad things so
it might slip out once in a while that's
just like did you ever consider a
different like lipstick like you know
what i mean like like i feel like when
you're friends because i know andrew my
co-host reads like every comment and and
knows and is probably validated when i
say something annoying and he hated in
the moment and then he's like yeah they
[ __ ] hated her too for him like
what's this i feel real if they hate
it's not real like the bad comments
aren't real it's like the good comments
are like i like it
you know when they nail the thing that
you're like i only thought i knew well i
just remember once saying this guy like
i was he said something about me ha
being hairy or something i was like i
waxed my mouth she was like i was
talking about your cheeks i was like oh
wow
so i have hair underneath like on the
top of my big cheekbones here
and then my my threading lady always
wants to take it off and i'm like no no
no that's my little wolf patch but is
that an unattractive thing to have oh my
god
i think it makes your makeup set a
little like off your face that's why i
have like did you do the shaving thing
though i've done it before where i've
literally just raised like with just
shaking
i don't like that it's yeah it's just it
it always when you put on your makeup
afterwards you kind of forget you're
like oh my god it's so sweet
it'll be like a day but it's yeah it
grows and you have to be in like a
loving relationship because you can't go
on a first date i did it before a
special one time and i and i cut myself
it looked like i was in a street fight
like i literally just because i'd never
done it my sister had gotten these
little like face razors and they i found
one in my bag i feel like it's just
another thing that i do or you're trying
to self-sabotage yeah yeah she started
[ __ ] i'll just say bleeding
everywhere i like to say this yeah if if
kalyla if like if i if you and i were in
some kind of situation like where we
were a thing i don't know what that
means but i would i think i would think
that your face hair is like very you and
it's like very cute i would be like
shaving yeah
no yeah i think it's fine i just you
just choose what you're insecure about
like i just i'm not going to care about
it i just was
maybe she thought it wasn't a good look
my
lady they're trying to get she's three
dollars by the way threading women i
don't want to like hurt
why do we have to why is it so cheap
it's too cheap i know it's ten dollars
i'm like you gotta like up your van
they're so sweet women that thread have
generally been very like maternal and i
used to get my threading lady used to
you know wax my vagina and i used to
like almost like to go even though it's
the most painful thing i stopped going
because she would do the thing where she
like goes like this to like kind of
distract me after they rip it they go
like this they go like they like pat you
and it just felt so maternal like you're
gonna be okay that i used to feel like
this weird attraction to her of like
just stick around like wanting to stay
with her like not wanting to let her go
it made me kind of sad actually though
do you guys get do you get a bikini wax
like what what's that i just shave now i
shave like i shave not like really yeah
i have hard wax oh let's do a good job
let's do that do it yeah i'm in i'm
signing up wait uh where do i be full
bikini wait just bikini you're not doing
full brazilian i would i like i like
brazilian stuff and all would you do you
guys shave i take it all the way i don't
shave i wax you but how often because
you gotta grow a little bit back to get
some tug so here's um i don't know if
you'll find this unfortunate or
fortunate but i actually don't grow up
pubic hair anymore you want me to show
you nikki yes oh my god this is how it
does
did when i asked
the top of my [ __ ]
oh my god
now show us the bottom of your [ __ ]
through the bottom
i really didn't think she was going to
show me the whole thing but that's a
great topic wait when you went over to
whitney's for the first time how fast
did she show your vagina it was like she
facetimed me on the way there
in case i lost service yeah um and you
do lose service at that stage it stayed
out there uh yeah i saw every i saw her
[ __ ] so it's so great so it made me
feel really connected to her like i was
just like
and then you realize she does it to
everyone maybe not no but it was she's
uh yeah she's free we we actually got
naked yesterday and got like spray tans
and i saw her pretty much head to toe
naked and i was too and it was like very
vulnerable and like i just never get
naked in front like i i do sometimes but
like just we've we've never got i've
never show she's always here
but i've never shown her mice and i felt
like she and then she was saying the
thing of like i want to compliment your
body but i don't want to because i want
to make it a thing and i'm like well you
just give me something then why were you
guys eating each other out when this
happened or yeah i mean yeah her mouth
was full but i could still hear what she
was trying to say did your parents ever
get naked in front of you no no no no no
naked family oh yeah we're asian oh
just in their underwear yeah you had
like men in the house just in their
underwear it's always there's always
something for the nudity and also it's
like spa is a big part of asian culture
so it's like nudity it's just not i like
that but what about um sex does that
come in hand in hand with like do you
guys talk openly about sex in my family
it was very matriarchal so my all my
aunts were basically they were the
original trash tuesday they were filthy
really um but um that's just i i don't
think yeah maybe that was just my family
we owe them money
nikki i have a question for you so
you i'm a as you know i'm a huge fan of
your podcast thank you i have been a
listener since the previous iterations i
know you listened when i was like
my parents it was
and i still think about having a really
depressing podcast how cool that was
that you were literally nikki talks so
openly it's very similar to us but like
she's
alone though no no one like she's
[ __ ] she challenges
my parents
she shares so much that you really feel
like am i on a phone call with her right
now like she's just telling me so much
and i'm just i wanted to check in with
you like mental health wise because you
were sharing so much that i related to
and i was like trying to i like reached
out to you yes i'm just curious
what like what's your current mental
health are you on meds like how are you
feeling yes i'm on meds and uh it was
really helpful because when i was doing
that podcast so i had this show on
sirius called you up it ended in april
of 2020 and then
i was still at a deal with comedy
central to do a weekly podcast but i
because comedy was going away i was like
i'll just do it daily and just do
check-ins and then we started getting
ads bought and like so it ended up being
like an hour and then i was and then by
july i was like so [ __ ] depressed and
like the idea of talking for an hour by
yourself about what like i don't even
know it was just i went to some really
dark places and was kind of like [ __ ] it
like i don't care i'm probably gonna
kill myself so what do i care what i put
out like not like very long
but yeah yeah it was just like i was
miserable and um putting it all out
there and a lot of people
just kept saying like it sounds like you
have adhd like and i'd always thought i
had depression but all the things i was
like hating myself about being messy and
being
just
just messy really like being a mess in
every way and like
like just all the self-doubt all the um
just
the obsessive thoughts about self-doubt
like i didn't know that that was a form
of add i always thought it was
depression that i like had these
thoughts of wanting to kill myself but
it was really like
i would i would get on a thought and i
would just run it all the way to the
place of killing myself as opposed to i
don't know it was it was a symptom of
adhd people were like women are
misdiagnosed with it all you know
they're we all go by what boys
have like they run around women can't
really run around because we're
not told we can when we're in school
like we get boys get to run around and
teachers go ugh boys
sit down and it's but girls run around
they're like what are you're weird like
girls aren't supposed to have this boy
energy right it's like embarrassing so
you just like stay and you're like you
get weirder like girls exhibit different
symptoms and um
and i had always been on zoloft and
prozac and [ __ ] everything for
depression and it
it made like the
low lows go away but it just didn't make
me like
feel any better about myself my
self-esteem was still [ __ ] um i was
faking it all the time just trying to be
someone i wasn't and then as soon as um
i really started reading symptoms of
adhd it just all of a sudden having a
name for all the things you hate about
yourself that isn't i knew depression
wasn't my fault but i didn't know
having a messy room not being organized
never not being able to manage my money
losing things constantly
having like everything stained with
spray tan like not having nice things
breaking things like that right hands
are some type of add foam
we don't have enough time to lay outside
okay feeling stained i felt like a
stained person i still do like there are
times where i'm just like i can't have
nice things
i will stain them because i'm just
inherently bad yeah but here's the thing
you just buy new ones i
uh anxiety about buying things and
creating waste and like
adding to landfills like then i have an
ocd about that which create which makes
me hold on to things that are dirt it's
crazy so that's why i still have esther
it's just so nice
to like it's just nice when there's a
name for the thing you think is just you
you guys
i'm just going to say it i love my
theragon it's so good it's really i
think it's my boyfriend
uh well another thing for dave to be
jealous
you guys don't let the stress of daily
life weigh on your body whether you're
an elite athlete or someone like me
just trying to make it through the day
tension free theragon can absolutely
help
theragun is a handheld percussive
therapy device that releases your
deepest muscle tension using a
scientifically calibrated combo of
depth speed and power and it's as quiet
as an electric toothbrush
the gen 4 theragon doesn't just feel
good it gets to the source of the pain
by releasing tension using theragon's
signature percussive therapy which goes
60 deeper than vibration alone
whether you want to treat your muscle
tension from working out an injury or
just stresses of everyday life there's
no substitute for the theragon gen4 and
that is the absolute truth the oled
screen and design make you feel like
you're holding something from the future
just go to their site and check it out
and the theragun app learns from your
behaviors and suggests guided routines
i'm telling you guys
this cuts my recovery in half amazing no
my lower back was so bad and then i
pulled from laying yeah when i pulled
the theragun out and used it it was
completely better like no it it's it's
just better and they have all these cool
attachments
depending on what part of the body the
software you guys can try theragon for
30 days starting at only
dollars go to
therabody.com trash tuesday right now
and get your gen 4 theragun today that's
therabody.com trash tuesday
therabody.com
trash tuesday and i have to say if
you're looking for a like a premium gift
for this holiday season for someone
special this is definitely the way to go
oh hey
liquid death
a tall can of
soothing
sensual water they get to feel cool like
the drinkers slash esther's dream
sponsor i mean i'm so she was wearing
their merch
the other last episode i think you guys
may start noticing that there are
strange tall boys of beer in the bottled
water section of your local stores well
it's not beer it's actually mountain
spring water from the alps and it's
called liquid death and we all drink it
every day
why is it called liquid death ester
because it will brutally murder your
thirst and also their infinitely
recyclable tall boy cans are helping
bring death to plastic bottles whoa and
they also donate 10 of the profits from
every can sold to help kill plastic
pollution and they're just it's just
cool plastic isn't actually recyclable i
don't know if you know that it's not
recyclable anymore most plastics that
you throw in the recycling bin actually
just gets sent to the landfill because
it's not profitable to recycle aluminum
is infinitely recyclable and actually
profitable for recycling facilities i'm
just going to say something um you know
how when you're at a concert or where
you're someplace that's social and you
just want to hold something yes because
your your hands don't know what to do
with itself with themselves and you get
in a lot less trouble if you hold one of
these and you
kind of look like you're a part of the
party dude this is my this is what i've
always wanted like it's so you just feel
oops you feel cool also water weirdly
tastes better coming out of this i don't
know why you guys can get free shipping
on all water and merch at
liquiddeath.com
trash that's liquiddeth.com trash or
grab some at whole foods sprouts and
7-eleven
yeah cause you suddenly feel seen and
reality it's so funny to not have grown
up in a family that my family loves
having add all they talk about is having
add my dad's 80 and takes like add
courses still he loves it he's like well
with adds little add jokes he calls it
uh attention deficit high definition
like he's just got like yeah jokes about
80 days
high definition is amazing and he i
might have
given it to him but um yeah he has that
great like he's just like so into it and
my parents went and did an 80d seminar
before the pandemic and they showed up i
swear to god they showed up to the
seminar and they said they didn't have
enough chairs and they forgot the
pamphlets it started 20 minutes late
they were like laughing so hard it was
just like the most
disorganized event yeah
i think you can work on it too though
you can it's not just something you have
to treat with meds like there's ways to
manage your life but i think one of the
biggest things was just
letting myself off the hook for it and
not thinking even when i was like you
know all i do is ever talk about this
but i was anorexic when i was 18 almost
died blah blah blah i always felt like
i chose that like it just even when i
see anorexic girls now i'm just like eat
something like what are you doing like i
can't even even though it almost killed
me i had for years i still look at them
and i'm like god why are you trying to
be skinny like just eat something like i
still have that and i went through it so
it's hard to have sympathy for yourself
or for others for mental illness it
seems like people choose it especially
depression like just get up and uh make
your bed in the morning go for a walk
it's for sure that's my dad are you
kidding me i literally and i can't know
when i was really really depressed
i was sleeping on a couch every day but
people were like you just need some
exercise in sunlight i was like sunlight
like but no i needed medications
obviously that would help listen on a
walk with a friend would have those
would help
if you were capable of doing it you
would do it do it dude and i know the
door is you could walk out the door you
have shoes you have uh that's why it's
suppression
there's something getting in between you
and doing the thing you know will help
you it's like it's like people that are
overweight it's like they know how to
lose weight it's not like it's just
there's something inside them that is
like well that's food addiction which is
a whole other thing which that's like
but the addiction is like like if you go
back like all of the addictions it's all
childhood trauma exactly what really
happened to me to be like completely
honest is like it was the depression but
it was also i was finally
so my eating disorder just went and like
took different iterations throughout
like as soon as i discovered comedy i
was like okay well i gotta figure out
how to not look like a skeleton because
i have a reason to live now so i started
eating but like then i just started just
you know messing around with food
exercise bulimic
you know throw up bulimic um i never did
um diuretics or anything but like i and
then i would do and then for the past i
would say
five years i was just intermittent
fasting which is like adult anorexia and
so and now everyone's it's like fine to
do it like i'm not eating all day
because it's crazy that's what gwyneth
does and now it's acceptable it's not
something you have to lie about so i
would just starve all day this is this
is the past like five years not eat
anything all day just do lattes all day
and then um
and then start eating at night in the
fast for them
it doesn't it's my own rules i made my
own rules that worked for me because i
didn't you know i could maintain weight
because i just want to eat a little bit
you make yourself when i started eating
at night like i would i would go to the
comedy sellers living in new york at
time go to the comment seller i would
order like uh the whole table would be
covered with my food and it's all like
salads and low calorie things because i
can eat a ton of it and not feel like
gross
and people would always come over and be
like you know sharad would be like nikki
you eat like a runaway rabbit like he
would always say and i would just go i
have an eating disorder like i would
just say it because it's like i just do
and then why is your hand in my tip
her chance would you guys would you eat
a banana with us right now
[Music]
one of the big principles from like my
eating disorder yeah what did you learn
was there are no bad foods
yeah it's really hard but i really
believe it now i i have ways to go
like you always that's so you're all
though like there's no no no foods are
bad i can eat any food i want to there's
no bad foods nothing is naughty nothing
is shameful
like and that's a real and then also
like always just nev what you said like
if you're hungry you have to eat like
there's no like oh i'll just push it
like that's that's just gonna lead you
to binge so there's no point and
whenever someone goes on a diet and is
like i'm doing this new thing i go
you'll lose weight but i promise you it
will come back i promise you you will
have a moment of weakness and won't be
able to stop because
everyone and and i realized also that
the the biggest tool i've like learned
and this always i always like to share
this because it's just helped me in so
many ways like
like i recent i like
started smoking pot again a lot and
depending on it so much because that's
why i got so depressed i mean annie
every time i talk to you you're either
on or too
long you're totally off
i quit weed every single day i go to my
trainer did i go i haven't smoked a week
because she was like you're like living
this healthy lifestyle you're gonna
naturally like it's gonna just not fit
your lifestyle anymore
and i'm like totally and then i was like
i haven't smoked tweet in so long and i
was like wait it's been a day
that's a long time when you smoke weed
every day i'm smoking all the like i'm
smoking like you're like you like have
an edible top right i'm smoking i'm not
like it's not that i believe i can
control myself
when life because everything's kind of
you gotta flow with things but
i would smoke i'm doing a thing i don't
like like i'm smoking in a way where i'm
getting too high
i'm staying at the comedy story late i'm
talking to people i don't really like
want to talk to i'm like i'm eating like
i'm like eating i'm going to mcdonald's
i'm
staying up later than i want
it's just like not
i'm passing out before i can bang my
boyfriend like it's just like not like
it's like i'm not living like the life
that i want and i know that i'm i i
don't it's not that i like being
high as much as i like doing something
bad it's like a like ooh and my with
with food too it's funny because like
the way i kind of gave myself a break
and stopped being upset with myself
about like overeating or whatever
is i realized that my dad when we were
like my whole life has always been like
hey let's go to the grocery store and
get something b.a.d and it was like our
bad thing so then i'm like i'm just
being like my family and it's yeah it's
fun it's like sweet it makes me feel
like them more and it makes me able to
not
like go crazy or if i go crazy i have no
shame in it it's really just breaking
the for me the pattern of shame and i
just do whatever i want and my body can
be whatever my body is like because i'm
working out now and it's very easy i
made a list of all the negative reasons
why i shouldn't smoke pot what are you
and then i was going to write all the
lists no esther never stopped we like
but i'm just this is what i'm so curious
i don't think you have a problem with it
it's actually an amazing thing i have a
problem with you quitting but like
because honestly nikki like you are i
actually think about you because you
masturbate
because i think about the night that you
shot with us on a loan together and oh
my god it was so high for that you were
so high you took that was such a bad
idea you were no no no no no you were
just oh that was one of my biggest
regrets was being high for that wait for
that show you need to listen to my
sentences
i literally was like wow that was so
cool she was like comfortable she was
really funny she was like in a good mood
easy to talk to i was like
i i really i just always clock that as
like oh that's really interesting like
that was cool and like i look at you as
like a good example interesting because
i let's go get [ __ ] up yeah
i mean but what did you feel i felt like
i i mean i honestly don't think i did as
well as i could have done if i weren't
high like i know for a fact i'm sure it
was fine and i feel like what you've
already told me you would be hard on
yourself either way
right but at least with this way like i
knew there were things happening because
i was high that i couldn't can i say it
out of my own head i
now if you don't like it exactly that's
why i think i smoked so much weight to
i'd be like
if i've ever smoked weed like before a
set which i very rarely do if the celery
i go i was hot i have a question for you
guys that's unrelated to wheat you want
to smoke a blood food um possibly but um
can someone explain to me what explain
to this immigrant what cuffing season is
yes mm-hmm oh yeah i think i like this
we'll do it okay i think cuffing season
is like a social media term for like
it's the christmas holiday season and a
lot of people are going to get engaged
or like start dating is that right i
think it's fine you're not out like
having fun in the summer so you just
find someone
a temporary lover yeah
just for this to bring around to your
family to be like here i have someone
and also it like everyone spends a lot
more time indoors so you want to find a
partner
down with a winter situation
yes it's just this like anxiety
before the holidays to find someone
because holidays is about family and
love and like
you know
warm cocoa looking out a window like a
frosted window or something the google
definition cuffing season refers to a
period of time where single people begin
looking for short-term partnerships to
pass the colder months of the year
cuffing season usually begins in october
and lasts until just after valentine's
day okay i was wrong i have a question
about this you said it so confidently
no i think it's a subconscious desire
that uh
and then yeah i don't think people are
like it's a coughing season no you can't
because people aren't gonna like agree
to it yeah and then you sort of just
part ways afterwards like casually and
then just bump you know just fist bump
and then goodbye it's probably like a
this is implied yeah like this is run
its course well after valentine's day
you're like
this is what you got
yeah valentine's day goes bad and then
you break up
yeah or like the sprints there's spring
is coming and that's usually when birds
are [ __ ] like squirrels
your life your love life all your
friends that's when you get rid of them
did you guys during the pandemic get any
weird phone calls from exes
oh i got weird messages and like phone
calls of regret from people
yeah because they were living with their
parents and they realized they let
someone go that could have been hanging
out like i definitely was like what did
thinking about pouring over the past
just seeing people with couples even
though i know it was hard during covet
to live with
you know a partner and it made a lot of
people split up i think single people
were like
[ __ ] i gotta focus on this for the next
one because it sucks being alone too
yeah i had such a like kind of like
i had like some obviously i went through
a lot of different feelings and some
were negative but at the the
pandemic was actually like when i look
back on it i like laughed all the time
it's so much fun and i was like but
that's because i was in a relationship
i'm like a brand new one if i would yeah
we just [ __ ] oh that's the perfect
situation
i was gonna break up with him so it was
like the pandemic it felt like i was
married at first sight what he had like
me to like stay but you were gonna break
up with him yeah because he's like was
so he was 25 at the time this guy you're
still with right yeah he's like what do
i do with this guy i can confirm but i
remember the call it's weird to think
about all that i'll be like hold on i'm
going to go outside babe and then and
you'd be like
how do i get out of this wait because he
was young that's why he was young it
just i always thought i had to like date
an older guy and i i was talking to my
friend marlo mk asante check him out
he's the best um he i was talking to him
on the phone and i was like yeah it's
like i'm dating this young guy and he's
so sweet and he's great but it's like if
i want to have kids and settle down i
gotta go with someone older he goes he's
like annie we're the old ones
you need him do you wanna he'll take
care of the
you don't want you don't want old sperm
annie no i don't want old sports no no
because then you end up really with a
[ __ ] up child like literally this the
people who host the show like all of us
that's what we are
we do fear the like there's always the
fear of he'll i'll get old and then he
won't be attracted to me sometimes i
just start crying sometimes i'm just
sitting there and i just start weeping
really yeah
because i'm like one day like i look
very young for my age now but everyone
hits their point there's going to be it
would have to start for you
and he's i pray for it so it's like but
you know what i got him he's got to stop
taking his what do we use for hair here
he's got to stay neutral
because i'm going to need him to bald
that's what i said okay if i did a young
guy if i were with a young guy there's
three things he has to be pale
broke and bald why i cannot date a young
guy that is extremely hot but you know i
can date a hot older guy but not a hot
carlos
but she has to be able to get him hard
because she wasn't able to stick on with
i couldn't get him but i couldn't get
him home
and that cheek hair i thought maybe
you'd be able to do it
is there any like age discrepancies that
come up that are just so glaring that
you're like he's so mature it like very
rarely does and honestly he knows
everything i know and i'm like is it
because your brother was older because
your parents are right but they're
always laughing together yeah like i've
been around them and they're always
giggling at something like have an
immaturity to you know events like you
are you have like a fun young contrast
you have a high school cool girl fun
energy to you so it makes sense
um
whenever i'm like
like there's like a younger person i'm
like oh i can't date them because people
will be like
that'll they'll make fun of me for it
and i'll feel older than i already feel
right because in comparison but i i
think that it's and it's not the same as
men dating younger women because i do
feel that men date younger women because
they look good you're not seeing this
guy because he looks young or because
he's less like
like i feel like guys date younger women
and they're like she's she's so mature
and it's like that's not really this
yeah i know it's because you want like
uh someone that looks young no he is and
i do think that it's also by the way
wait i just want to throw shade at guys
that like younger women because it's
like did you just not get laid in height
and also are you jealous because they
could have just dated you because you
look young
you act annoying and old
[Laughter]
sorry i thought i i got lucky with bobby
being 13 years older than me but the
[ __ ] just won't crack no people
that shocks me every year i look at our
pictures together and i'm like [ __ ] we
he might look younger than was there any
question in your mind like when you guys
got to i don't know your story but like
was that a
did that
weigh in on you being with him that no
the moment i met him i was like this
[ __ ] acts like he's 12. perfect
i love you yes
he's i i love how he's forever just in
like this peter pan yeah sort of yeah i
love that about bobby too i know it's so
fun we had so much fun in the comments
wait you touched his p you kissed this
we kissed we kissed on the mouth too
like yeah like he he always like starts
to introduce me and i always come out
and just like start my own intro like
before he's done
and then we're in the main room of the
comedy store and then he we had like a
real good moment we're like i love you
and then we like i grab i always like
grab his nipples sorry yesterday that's
her that triggers me because my nipples
are so sensitive
that i'm going to get them no
no i'm going to get them in enough weed
we'll get i'm going to numb them
in hawaii i'm going to put some cbd
cream on them with your tongue
yes with my tongue
so tell me how you kissed my boyfriend
okay
and then it was like this it was like
really slow it was like
and then i was like wait and then i had
him turn around
to his penis his penis oh my god i knew
you were so happy i knew you would like
it i love that that makes me
no because i had the same thing when
when annie got naked in front of dave
while he was on a zoom writer's room it
made me like i feel butterflies and when
whitney's naked on facebook i love like
sharing my naked friends
we should always be naked i do too i i i
like
i mean this is a weird thing about but i
like when someone i'm dating like
maybe hooks up with other girls and like
tells me about it
here's what i'm really into like in the
beginning of a relationship when i'm
before i get fully emotionally invested
i want to see him [ __ ] someone else in
front of me what so i'm oh
where they're like [ __ ] my wife she's
hot i'm proud of her we're hot
husbanding but it's very it's it's like
i like that i like when i i like when
girl when girls hit on my boyfriend but
i don't want them i'd like to always be
the one they're like no i want you kala
let's go back
yeah
what did you just say you said you wanna
before you date someone you wanna watch
him what you wanna watch him [ __ ] can i
make it better can i make it better
um
before she dates a woman who wants to
watch it
you like it now
esther before i get fully emotionally
invested if we're in the first three
months window of being together yeah i
need there to be a threesome and i need
to feel
that feeling of like it makes him hotter
and more desirable to me to watch him
[ __ ] another girl but i just want to
know girls are desiring him it's funny i
went with todd to the comedy story and i
wasn't actually mad at this girl at all
but there's uh like a cute girl who does
uh rose battle and she like didn't see
me i was like coming in behind him and
she was like
um she was like he gave her a hug but he
like kept his like pelvis out
and she was like whoa why didn't she
give me a real hug and i was like cause
this isn't like trash hoes like you
[ __ ] and it was like a very good moment
but i was like
but i it was funny and it was yes and i
liked that it happened
and i wasn't like i didn't think she was
even like doing a thing but it was just
like a fun yeah bobby passed his window
with me because i gave him not three
months but a whole year right i was like
we shouldn't you know let's reopen the
world and then after the first year i
was like you know it's i can never like
i love you now i'm in love with you what
if we got one of your ex-boyfriends to
[ __ ] bobby in front of you would you
like that right to [ __ ] me no to [ __ ]
each other in front of you would you
like that i kind of they would do it for
you i hear how they pick up the phone
when you call i they would do it for you
look i think that while bobby is mostly
heterosexual i do think that he would
you know
suck a dick or two and it would not turn
me off i'd be into that i used to make
my boyfriends in college kiss boys it
was like i wanted to just i wanted to
force them into that like openness
that's like a dominating you're like
dominating yeah that's like pissing on
me yeah oh my god did you see the the
i mean i want to do it to carlos on
stage wait wait you've never peed up
after you've never been peed on right
we've already established that uh no i
haven't waited can we do a sweatshirt
where carlos closes his eyes and lays
down and it ends up being jaunt
the mouth part i wouldn't mind it on my
skin but like the mouth i don't know
on my head
oh okay and my eyes and my face is that
the neutral plan it's part of the harry
potter plan
and um it was after being like i wanted
to be completely like dominated by a man
so i was like you know i'm a whole treat
me whatever but that was the end of it
he didn't even ask permission he just
like threw me in a tub and he was like
don't you [ __ ] move don't you [ __ ]
move and then he like peed all over me
on my face and everything and i was
my my natural instinct was to be so
grossed out and offended
but then after it all like i couldn't
have felt
better like i was like skipping that's
what we skipped out of there
and like telling stories sports for
years my
horrious moments where i feel degraded
in the moment or like maybe on paper it
would seem like a degrading act i
literally say that i've i've skipped out
afterwards like i remember skipping to
my car after i like jerked a guy off
into a toilet one time a guy that i like
wanted it was my first hand job i ever
gave but i remember being like you're so
gross and then i saw myself in the
mirror and i'm like hey girl this is
actually kind of funny like this is
hilarious
like push through like uh
i have such fear of like sex with men
and doing sex acts and like and so when
i'm able to do it i'm like
it gives me more self-esteem being a
[ __ ] than than doing well it's
controlled too like it's like a control
thing and it's like i feel like with
role playing and all that sort of stuff
it's like and i think about back in the
day when i would like i would hook up
with guys for like a month or whatever
choke spit in my mouth like all this
crazy stuff and it's like i never was
going to be in a relationship with them
but the sex i could like it was almost
like disassociating i wasn't me i was
like in this crazy thing and it was like
getting me through it but i did do for
my
uh through my coach through jim ford and
i did i'm doing this course and i
i one of the things in the homework is
to like write your life story in three
pages and then to see like where your
stories and your kind of like themes are
and mine is just literally i moved
around a lot my mom told me to be
smaller to like fit in and i was raped a
lot is that why you're jealous of me
because i'm small well i have to be yes
you wish you could be you don't shine
the way you
the way you're very uh matt
i'm like so stuck still on you wanting
to watch the guy [ __ ] someone else like
because i'm almost like getting
confidence in myself i'm like am i like
a daddy that like i know you can only
[ __ ] me like i no i don't know
so esther
what did george just say mickey's like
yeah it's normal you're normal oh like
we're the outliers here and like it's
well yeah i don't think it's creepy but
i don't if i don't see why
like i don't know i
i think it's kind of strange when you're
in a relationship to expect the guy that
you're with to like never
come by someone oh no for sure i think
it's a control thing ultimately for me
where it's like porn um i
like i realize i'm very much accepting
of the fact that you will always find
someone else attractive so therefore i
have to pick her yeah so i will always
pick them i'm still in control over and
then you're observing
right and it's almost like a release
it's a release of my own fear dude you
are so annoying i wouldn't i i would
john and carlos yeah
corrin i hope was that corinne fisher
okay okay don't worry karina is so funny
she's like she's skank best like
spreading her out i'm like their
pictures are so she she did she had such
a boss night there because she brought
her young hot boyfriend and got him all
these dances and it was so it was really
cool and we were just chatting while
these hot women are like grinding on her
body i did that to a boyfriend once i
had this boyfriend years ago and i took
me so hot and he came to visit me in
santa fe and i took him to this like
shitty club named cheeks where the the
line was you don't need the ocean to
catch crabs and um
so so
we
i brought him there and he like wasn't
having a good time i was like come on
come on like what the hell and then he's
like my
mom um my moms are lesbians like i don't
want to see like he didn't like me being
like into the girls
because his mom left his dad for a woman
oh wow that's and he was like yeah i'm
not into this not about you the time
that i've had had like my the guy i was
seeing like hook up with another girl
and it was always when i wasn't in town
i was like you know he's on a trip with
like for a bachelor party or whatever
and i'm like yeah you can fool around if
you want like don't go down on a girl
don't like are rubbing cheating
no but i
rob and tugs like massage i wouldn't
mind it i would want to hear about it
but i do i'd prefer a professional
situation than them going and getting
for sure like a girl whose feelings are
involved i don't want like what guy has
ever gotten a [ __ ] from a random girl
at like a bar on like nashville and gone
i want to leave my girlfriend for you
like that's never happened so i just i'm
like go get a [ __ ] tell me about it
and the thing is when he has gone and do
done stuff he doesn't it's not like he's
like dying to do it like he's not like
please can i do this and i'm like i
guess it's like actually my idea and
he is like it's interesting because when
i'm doing when i'm fooling around with
another girl
if i was cheating on you i would try to
keep you out of my mind the whole time
like you would have to i would have to
like kill you in my room right but when
i'm hooking up with her i'm thinking
about you the whole time and i'm like oh
that's interesting he's like oh nicki
would really like if i did this and i
can't wait to tell her about this and
then he saves the story for me until
we're hooking up so he'll like the time
he did it he went on a trip and then we
met up um afterwards and we went through
the whole day just like not saying
anything even though i knew he had a
story and i did no details he was just
like i'm gonna get something done
tonight i was like okay and then we were
like the whole day like had this
fun day and then like as soon as we
started hooking up he's like do you want
to hear what happened i was like yes and
it was like the hottest
it was so hot and i didn't need to know
what she looked like or
uh if her [ __ ] was tighter than mine or
any of that like i just
like that i just felt yeah you can't get
into comparison no you have to just it's
a completely separate thing yes
that's hard easier said than done yeah
that's
why i know you're always i hope she's
hot it's almost like i don't want to
know because if she's not i'm like dude
do you like hot girls like am i
i hope
that gives him some um clout to me if
hot girls want him and i'm like good
luck like
you might be hotter than me but you're
not going to be funnier than me yeah i
mean now
like hot girls are funny always no
they're not uh
they're not looking at yourself
who are you
um i really
um
had times with my boyfriends where
i would go i would feel that way or like
guys that i was like hanging out with
i'd be like i'm the funniest like
there's no way those and then i realized
like oh there are so many guys that do
not want they don't want to a funny
it must be hard to be a girl like uh you
know guys don't like funny girl
all i get so many guys guys yes there
are some guys that do it's like a type
of guy that doesn't like feminine energy
men are not threatened by a funny woman
but generally being funny equals
intelligent
and
it's it's hard for them to and funny
women talk a lot and men don't like
women that are dude if you're a guy and
you don't like a woman who's funny women
are objects to you saying this to the
camera you think women are objects
because you don't want them to talk you
don't want them to be funny no but they
can't
there's nothing you need to [ __ ] talk
about
they can't help it though esther you
don't get mad at them this is the new
thing it's not your fight [ __ ] we think
we're objects we're not when you say we
are being hot or funny but i also said
at the beginning this i want to be holes
so
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no it's actually how many holes
three holes i feel like i was sent to
this earth to hurt
to hurt you but it never works
no to give you to give you yeah no they
they like funny women they'll buy
tickets to our shows and be fans of us
but they don't want to they don't want
to marry a lot of men don't want to
marry funny women because it's like a
loud
a loud woman doesn't help men's survival
when we were all like without evolution
we have iphones i know but we haven't
updated to modern we're still operating
on like
we need steve jobs he wants to update us
yeah he [ __ ] died it sucks but like i
was even you know
you could let's just think about the
male comics that we know like bobby is
obviously different because he
is attracted to a funny woman who's like
energy yes okay feminine by the way no
that doesn't count kalila's super hot
it's like she is super hot but she's
also funny
you could i feel like an object in this
room right now
you have a very like feminine like your
voice is like soothing to me and almost
asmr and it is there is a feminine
energy to your voice that it's like
relaxing and makes me feel like you tell
that to my shoulders oh [ __ ] i didn't
look at you straight on this one's from
the side oh my god look at her
do you guys think you would have big
dicks if you had a dick yeah i would i
my dad's dick was pretty sizable did it
fit in your mouth or
let me see
yeah
nikki thank you so much for being here
oh my god you guys i could talk to you
all day you are thank you for being
authentic hilarious women that are so
beautiful and fun
and good friends like they give the
trash each other but like are also
just kind to each other and supportive
keep each other in check i have good
lighting
do you see the joy she gets when i trash
and i just like like the divine goes
through me
[Laughter]
i'm telling you i can make fun of anyone
but with you it's like i'm heaven sent
to you
it is special the connection is special
mickey what would you like for both oh
um you know
yeah my podcast i do a daily podcast
that's kind of like a morning radio show
you can jump in any time you don't have
to listen to all the episodes to fit in
um and it's monday through thursday it's
called the nicki laser podcast
and that's it and you're on tour i'm on
tour oh yeah that too i'm so bad at
promo i'm on tour as well and uh
yeah i know denver um
san francisco portland calgary
and i think that's it are you doing all
theaters now or are you doing clubs
don't know yes yay well thank you so
much to all of our listeners another
crazy day where i have to go home and
think about what i said
and
potentially have long conversations at
home
i just let it go i go if you got
offended i'm sorry i definitely didn't
mean it and i just say the things i
think as fast as possible because that's
how the comedy comes forgive yourself
yeah i forgive myself
you know and guys
i'm paying this girl what's her name
maybe they could write directly to her
portia say dear portia isn't that a
great name such a good name i love
hershey
all right you guys we'll see you next
week
[Music]
you